a thousand miles off the coast of
California halfway to Hawaii and
scientists are trawling for plastic this
is the center of the Great Pacific
Garbage Patch the largest accumulation
of ocean plastic on the planet and the
most comprehensive ever survey show
there's even more debris out there than
feared by draging nets along the surface
in hundreds of locations with further
analysis from the air scientists working
with the ocean cleanup foundation have
calculated there are 1.8 trillion pieces
of plastic weighing 80 thousand tons but
up to 16 times more than previous
estimates so many different you know
size and shapes and you can you know you
can find objects that you may see in
your kitchen right and so you so far
from landings and so it's so alarming
and then you know you have like those
larger debris and all those nets and you
found dead fish around it and it's you
know we're really causing harm out there
the Pacific Garbage Patch is the largest
of five hotspots around the world where
ocean currents sweep together plastic
the new research produced density maps
with red the highest concentration
showing it's now three times the size of
France drifting fishing nets that have
been lost overboard or abandoned make up
much of the plastic the scientists also
found toys household bottles and
containers some with production dates
stretching back to the 1970s British
scientists are horrified once plastic
enters the ocean it can persist for we
think thousands of years it doesn't ever
go away it just breaks down into smaller
and smaller particles to it into micro
plastics and as we've seen these micro
plastics are able to enter the food
chain later this year the ocean cleanup
foundation will launch a long floating
collection screen which will be left in
the Garbage Patch Engineers believe a
fleet of the devices could remove 50
percent of the plastic in five years
other scientists are skeptical and argue
it's better to keep plastic out of the
ocean in the first place
Thomas More Sky News